well joel according to police a man in
his 50s is facing charges for refusing
to wear a mask on board a flight it
happened on a westjet flight last night
from calgary to london's gatwick airport
around 9 30 the calgary police airport
patrol team was called to remove an
unruly passenger who had allegedly
physically assaulted a member of the
crew the flight had been underway for
about an hour when the decision was made
to turn the plane around a westjet
spokesperson says a situation escalated
from the passenger not wearing a mask
masks are still mandatory for flights
departing canadian airports westjet says
its crews are trained to manage a
variety of situations there is no
tolerance for an incident that could
impact safety for those on board in a
statement the airline says our cabin
crew members show up daily to ensure the
safety of our guests in operations
over the last two years they have been
at the forefront of the pandemic
navigating an extremely complex
operating environment and required to
enforce restrictions such as mass
compliance as canadians return to travel
we will never compromise on making the
right decisions in support of the safety
and well-being of our crews and guests
calgary police say when the plane landed
mamudu berry was arrested the
52-year-old faces charges including
assault common nuisance endangering life
and failing to comply with crew members
instructions under canadian aviation
regulations
westjet says the flight did eventually
take off and safely arrived at its
destination school global zeiss sudo
reporting live from the airport tonight
thank you aina